that's clear go
[Music]
welcome to the gameplay demo walkthrough
of CD Projekt RED upcoming title
cyberpunk 2077 a narrative driven
open-world RPG set in a dark version of
the future before we start a small but
important disclaimer the gameplay are
about to see is from a work in progress
version of the game everything you see
is potentially subject to change in
cyberpunk 2077 you can fully customize
your character using a deep
customization system for this demo we're
going to play a female keep in mind that
what you see here is not final we just
want to give you a glimpse of what will
be possible in the released game this is
an RPG so before we get into our
appearance we need to define our
backstory what you choose here will
unlock different possibilities later in
the game also you can use an array of
different options to modify how you look
these include body type hair style
tattoos makeup skin tone and many many
more
but visuals aren't everything you'll
also be able to customize your initial
attribute setup you'll notice we didn't
pick a class cyberpunk 2077 features a
fluid class system and you'll be able to
modify your class throughout the game
this demo takes place near the beginning
of the game v and her friend Jackie
along with a net runner named Kiba are
hired to find and retrieve a missing
person a girl whose locator implant went
dumb that's clear go
well 37 on your right side cyberpunk
2077 is a first-person role-playing game
this perspective enables us to maximize
your immersion should have full access
into point eight seconds reached your
turn what I live the way I know alarms
neutralized
[Music]
[__] late is that her that our target
V who is too simple not our girl they
take blood it looks like these
scavengers are kidnapping people to
harvest their implants
[Music]
okay things are about to get heat we'll
take a reflex booster that temporarily
allows us to use the perez McCartney
this is Korres Nicole
he's Boban
[Music]
can't be sick
got none to [__] at you
got a window on the left
this anymore
[__] layout shows only one room left
the bathroom go sure hope our target
their copper oh nice thank I gotta got
our target we make it she live this does
not look good no in a minute checking
into biome on Sandra Dorset NC 5704 42
got a winner
well she will be if we can get her to a
hospital she's trauma team platinum to
platinum shouldn't eat each other food
dinner she need something's jamming the
biome on signal talk to me t bug virus
probably locator neuro socket should be
a shard slotted inch it's probably on
that if we clear it free up the signal
TT could actually drop in take her off
our hands got the shard removing it now
done make an emergency evacuation unit
has been dispatched and is due to arrive
at your location in 180 seconds biome on
claim from all deer in three minutes
like a [__] let's get out of here
your premium plan will cover 90% of the
projected cost of your net
[Music]
yeah that she's flatlining do you need
to know what's going on
Jackie err hypo China she's stable yeah
well uh huh get her outside cuz it turns
out a virus disrupted the girl's locator
implant we fixed that and now help is in
bhau's just pulled up outside
get away
[Music]
click the patient on the stretcher
step back I said step back
51:33 to control patient and c57 fear of
4-4-2 secured stimulants being
administered Stefanie milligrams
dopamine 110 Nora
hey give us a lift out of here
cutting connection debug out I'll clear
that was trauma to blow a kind of
high-end premium medical insurance time
for what book said we've delivered the
target and teba has notified us that the
scavengers have called in reinforcements
let's get out of here before they arrive
I get that Eddie's for new wheels now I
and something real fine - how about
Joanna probably blow it out on booze in
three days talking about somebody else
Jack be more than a content a combat
[Music]
[Applause]
cyberpunk is a mature visceral
experience and as such it will let you
explore a variety of different
interactions with the game world and as
you just saw its people Johnny sovereign
been a year since he went on his last
ride in that Scotch wait for something
better you know what I mean the job was
a success and V obviously has some money
to burn hey sup V look I need to talk to
you that was as big as my balls and I've
got a hot date with my Ripper duck come
on I now make the doc wait pull some
pants on you're good on get down here
subway entrance with your iron
[Music]
okay Jackie has just told us he has some
big news for us
and we have an appointment with our
River today before we leave let's take a
good look around our party good morning
night City the song on the radio is by
rocker boy Johnny silver it's part of
our creative process to draw inspiration
from the pen and paper system created by
Mike pon Smith and to put our own 2077
spin on
let's go grab our geek
[Music]
okay we'll take these trusty pistol
and also grab our jacket
since cyberpunk 2077 is an RPG the
jacket not only provides us with
protective stats like armor but it also
increases our street street cred is a
form of experience the player acquires
by completing side missions it is used
to unlock new vendors and content
throughout night scene all right let's
go meet Jack these current apartment is
located inside a mega build a huge
building complex that forms a micro
Society of its own in this timeline and
technology in the world have evolved in
some ways that seem familiar when but
entirely surprising in others as an
example in this world lab people pay
with Eddie's slang for Euro dollars we
make sure to route every detail in the
world's law so everything has its
purpose and slays believable
a big part of our RPG experience is
having a world that is interactive here
a generic ad has morphed into an
advertisement specifically tailored to
the political informing her of the
nearest venues you can purchase the
product in this case it shows us where
to find some Nicola so
even mother
and lecture
this is Wilson one of night city's many
guns we won't be checking his wares but
you can purchase and upgrade your
weapons and gear throughout the city
then cyberpunk 2077 is set in night cr8
a bustling metropolis located on the
coast of the free state of north
California it's a dystopian similar
violence and oppression are the norm we
are working hard to make Knight City
fully realized seamless open world with
no loading screens currently we're in
watson a former industrial this world
where a crime now mixes with money
get big damn signal guns out three times
three times yo the piece of [__] now
give it back my editors
debut out that
give you some truth to that
we've greatly enhanced our crowd and
community systems to create the most
believable city in any open-world game
the city streets are bustling with
crowds of people from all facets of life
all living their lives within a full day
and night cycle
[Music]
okay there's Jack and finally she's
happening what's up jack Dexter DeSean
huh sound familiar
and there was attempt to you see these
outfits okay you see that caddy need to
walk on over there and get us a job ina
[Music]
fine I'll meet him talk ba0 rippers
you
it turns out we've caught the attention
of one of knight city's biggest players
Dexter DeSean a fixer a person who gets
things done he wants to meet up and
discuss a job guru let's see what he has
for us
yo miss v a pleasure
let's roll
scanning the serious job just now
playing got gains you and compared us
smashing up a scare home
you interested
interested sure tell me more glad to
hear before we can start in on this
though I need to be sure
assure you all right
all right in the nature of this test
start in the show
see I've got a classic tale for you
psycho game just doing his thing jump
the core convoy got away with deep
now I need need that little town bad bye
they call it the flathead of course I
got the Eddie's to buy it but me and the
Maelstrom boys ain't the best of friends
no flow to our convo see
who's the woman corporation she's on the
hunt for the dogs he sold the gang goons
info on the council got herself a
prisoner their chief suspect looks like
they're going on 20 hours since the
convoy was jumped and she still don't
have any guilty party kind of be
desperate by now be wise I think how you
could use it got any questions for me
fair honored all I think time I got to
work beautiful here's hoping my inkling
checks out
so see you at the afterlife soon as the
job's done do good and this will be the
start of a beautiful friendship based on
the heaps of Eddie's
it seems dexter has given us a test of
sorts to see if we're a word he wants us
to retrieve a piece of hi-tech combat
gear a local gang stole from the
military medical will be able to
approach this job from a variety of
angles let's try calling the military to
see where that leads hi
heard you were looking for some tech
let's talk on the horn Jesus
first exit off skyline going towards the
NID storms handle under the overpass
meet you there
the situation's tricky because the
contract Giver as a corporate agent who
seems a little high-strung before we get
down to business it's a great idea to
visit our River though
yeah yeah you see this camp I'll get got
a real whack take change your [__]
life
crime is a common occurrence night city
is not a safe place life here is not
easy
your heart chakra looks a little out of
whack babe be play out with Dex doll
here alright I'll check it out while I
wait for you me doctor vector will see
you now we're at a ripper doc clinic
Ripper Doc's are specialist vendors who
offer people the possibility to install
or upgrade their cyber we need to bump
up my specs and get a grip
really now finally neck [__] just got
real hit in the major leagues got a
chopped index - Shawn the Dexter - ah
yeah that is something but let me guess
hasn't paid you yet
quick Ryan Vick I'll bring you the
eddies later with interest you know I
will
last time I swear now sit
that's Karoshi best I've got and should
be about right under the circumstances
now Jackie
you peruse and shoes while I scan see
what's going on inside we're going to
install both an optical scanner mark one
like I said decent enough scanner
displays data on your cornea and a
subdermal weapon grip links not labeled
and to be perfectly honest not entirely
sure where the hell I got it still looks
like it'll talk to Karoshi check oh I'm
ready carve away okay I'll clean now for
the fun stuff they made you League on
yours right here just like that
thanks now a bit of an aesthetic and I
can start reading
feel anything duck play-by-play makes
you sound like a dentist you're always
going on and on don't be me now remember
I'm old I got a shaky Ganic hand could
slip lights out for a minute all right
good so let's test it
linking you in you might feel a little
discomfort
maybe blurred vision low contrast
glitches so how's it look to you with
the scanner we can zoom in on things and
take a closer look
this is fantastic beautiful time for the
scanner additionally we can analyze
objects get details on enemy weak points
or gang affiliation scanner should
eventually sink you to your thought
processes read your intentions Auto work
like a charm now draw your weapon you
should see your ammo count and a brand
new site the subdermal weapon links to
our skin and shows us weapon information
like ammo count and fire levels it also
increases the base damage on all
connected weapons vector not bad I don't
know what to say say you'll take this
and remember the dosage two whips now
and another two in an hour
thanks again you're the best Vic go on
kids showing what you can do and once
you hit the big time don't forget where
you came from
while some Ripper docks operate legally
others provide black-market services for
the right price they can even offer to
install illegal military-grade cyberware
left a few minutes ago said he'd wait
outside
well well Yoshi
well Vic's got a soft spot for you Hina
come on
how about you use them fancy as optics
to scan my new wheels sure you'll have
to let me take it where's Ben hey just
watch the big job
[Music]
problems
this guy looks an awful lot like one of
those scavengers we took out earlier so
that tells me there wasn't no
coincidence
[Applause]
[Music]
Jackie's car is a super-powered sports
car running on to to the super fuel of
the future players can explore night
city freedom in many different cars on
bikes and in other types of fields
[Applause]
this does not look good
it looks like the scavengers earlier
still angry
all right
I think we got rid of that was intense
night city never sleeps danger lurks
around every corner even in daytime
random encounters like these are an
example of how your actions directly
influence your open world experience
let's get the [__] out of here
okay Jackie
they're done riding our asses scavs
maybe should be looking for a new spot
to slice and dice not coming after us
who knows real messed up in their horse
cars saw it yourself
[Music]
many forces are fighting for control of
night city but the mega corporations are
the real show the agent we're going to
meet represents militant one of the
largest companies in the private
military set while we stop it
[Music]
remember the corpo off debts of shard
ringer she's in the area moving me let
me guess she's a hot cup of water
desperate when you think you can use
that see if I can yeah
since cyberpunk 2077 is an RPG
preparation will be key when dealing
with knight city's powerful especially
when these are core bugs instead of just
rushing in let's assess the situation
with our freshly installed Karoshi
optical scanner there let's take a
closer look
composite armor cars a [__] tank
Milotic about it sure you still want to
meet him
[Music]
yeah gotta do this don't you move a damn
muscle not unless I start that is
these guys are levels higher than we are
let's try to approach them carefully
Stout take it you were the one to call
yep we wanted
you
you're smart holding the hell down
what is I'll know and [__] thing
ready all set
are you here alone the core boughs have
hacked us through our personal link a
detector program the dialogue system in
cyberpunk 2077 is fully gameplay driven
I asked if you came alone yep
just little old me she's lying search
the area
phanie Gilchrist did he or another
[__] at militant week info to you or
anyone else about a convoy it might be
tempting to reach for the gun but the
consequences god I remember these guys
are really - [__] checks out you got
nothing on me not that you are dead
somebody shut him up take me home now
all right I have no idea who you're
working for or what you even want but
you better give me something solid or I
will end you
I've got an offer oh you are stretching
this better be [__] good
gang goons who ripped you off I know
where to find him
they got a bot I want give me the funds
to buy that but you can do it you want
with the gang I don't give a [__] about
the thieves
I want my mold
Frenship 50k just enough to buy you your
bot thing is chips got to make it into
the thieves terminal that's all I need
think you can do that and we got a deal
[Music]
fine I'm in
try to [__] me in anyway and I'll be
seeing you real soon you're making a
mistake
this cuts good is dead the agent gave us
the money to buy the bot we need from
the game by choosing to call the
militant early we have now opened up a
non-violent path through this quest of
course we could try and keep the money
but that would mean we'd have to take
the merchandise by force which requires
a lot of firepower
the little fish you know people tents no
signal so I stay put good thing too
went down about like I expected made a
deal and we're good to meet with
Maelstrom now yes
[Music]
be there soon what do you expect courts
don't forgive will forget even these
board [__] since that feel the pressure
that's why they're holed up in this
[__] praying to the Almighty trip
six gotta move the tech but they can't
cuz your new best friend from the trip
down tanked out SUV he's just begging
them to try how you want to do this even
now we can choose how to approach this
quest do we go in guns blaze or do we
try to negotiate for the plan simple we
pay with the corpus cred and get up
you're calling this for this demo let's
try the more diplomatic approach tough
[__]
all we needs for them to buy it
wanna talk
I'll strap Macmillan tech gear Lettieri
great hardware worth millions should
beat the guys were about to meet are
dangerous they are members of the male
strongman and their obsession with body
modification goes way beyond even this
world standards on their path to
becoming machines they don't shy away
from even the most extreme measures
anti-personnel mine shrapnel is better
my favorite 10 goons getting creative
with their gear it looks like they made
this abandon all foods meat factory
their hideout another one seriously baby
we should have taken him by surprise
little late for regrets like that got us
in their sights now just keep moving
stay cool you're just trying to spook us
remember we've chosen to buy the tech
not stealing hopefully this will get
fast and cheap this is a pretty well
guarded place you can imagine what would
have happened if we'd taken the violent
path
what
looking to buy a bot model MTO d12 looks
like a spider couch planting
beuker
well [__] sit down I'll stand can't move
on your culo makes you an easy target
sit down that really necessary hombre I
ain't your hombre
sit sit your ass down for I played a
bullet you Scott sit down
this ain't gonna end
we'll all right [__] it come on lighten
up
have a whiff
[Music]
now we can talk
you
suit yourself
the artists don't even got no standard
port bells and whistles though science
is wider than that of the human nervous
system its actuators are action and it
can go anywhere literally watch it holy
weeks too much
so what you think me up and let's get
the [__] out of here the buck I'll take
two questions what the [__] going on
and who the [__] is this
[Music]
you
got 50 large on this crutch positively
reeked of militant Dexter DeSean see
Dexter DeSean threats go plate saddle
[__] not him
we'll pay for the bot field away
how much you say you add 50 K threads on
this
move it
not smoothest deals but it worked out in
the end to the trick
whatever that trick is [__] [__] [__]
it turns out the cred ship we got from
the military agency fiend a virus tried
there sis their leader is making a break
for real attack at the end this way
before we figure out a way to leave
let's grab the splinter that controls
the bottom from one of these dead male
strummers
the inspection system allows us to take
a closer look at the Splinter you can
inspect specific items to reveal details
that can help in solving quests
okay let's equip the splint to our chip
where's with this done the body will now
follow us wherever we go
all right what else do we have you nice
a street modified tech shotgun tech
weapons fire rounds that penetrate walls
and other type stuff they also have an
alternate fire mode that allows you to
power up shots and deal more damage
it looks like there are several ways out
of this room like those gates for
example however you'd have to be a
skilled net runner to hack into this
term
luckily our engineering skills should
allow us to disassemble that maintenance
panel so we can get through the door
there are many skills in the game that
players can apply in solving problems
the engineering skill can be used to fix
disassemble and disarm devices block
passes through here we're gonna pass
through so at this point we're going to
unlock the abilities of a high-end
character to showcase some of the
different mechanics we have in the
one of the new weapon modules we now
have installed is a ricochet targeting
system connected to our eyes bounce
bullets off walls and hit enemies hiding
behind cover
this is another targeting system that
will reveal enemies behind walls paired
with the penetrating rounds of our tech
shot it's a deadly combination
looks like we found some loot this is a
smart gun it's one of the more advanced
weapons in the game allowing the bullets
to track and follow their target it's
one of many different weapons players
can acquire weapons are built of modules
that allow for deep customization and
progression this way you can be sure to
find something that will suit your place
the toughest bastards guarding this
route
you
[Music]
just to remind everything you've seen
and are about to see including this
particular feature about to show II is
from a work-in-progress version of the
game and may change over the course of
development okay
all that's its cover okay let's try
something different
Tommy we're going to take this guy down
and connect directly to his neural sign
in the world of cyber once you are
jacked into a net where everything it
connects to through this Maelstrom
gangman we've now connected to the gang
hideouts internal network this is the
building's personnel system let's focus
on the squad containing the Maelstrom
gang are we just connected from here we
can deploy software that affects the
whole squad for now we'll simply unlock
the ability to perform quick hacks all
right time to show off our new
high-level abilities with quicken using
the backdoor we unlock the minute ago
we'll install a virus that jams the
connection between the Maelstrom ganger
and his weapon this will prevent him
from firing
looks like he's having a problem nice
some of you might recognize these mantis
blades we can also double jump and
bounce off of walls which makes us a
very agile fast solo
[Music]
I'll check down here
sweet we just found a corporate tackle
for four weapons are top of the line
[Music]
let's scan this guy and see what's going
on it looks like Royce is back and his
prey
he's got an armored exoskeleton you
won't be able to get rid of him that
easily
our weapons are not dealing a lot of
damage because he's packing an
autonomous train
luckily the scan we performed earlier
rizal the weeks attacking should bring
the shield de
shields down let's finish him up
[Music]
okay let's put him down and get this job
over
that wasn't the smoothest raid but we've
got the bots and Dex should be happy but
think back what would have happened if
we hadn't met with the militant or told
Royce about the agent and her plans or
just decided to buy the bought ourselves
so many options so many possibilities
and each will have consequences that
will ripple through the game world and
your story and that's just one quest
let's head out and finish the job Bob
goddamn time let's get out of here
[Applause]
you know we really ought to work
together more often your chip had the
clap
that's not discrete you set me up I
[__] you over you [__] the gang over
somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [__] the Corp see how this
works now only the Corp gets what it
wants remember that being raging [__]
to whoever's doing my dirty work for me
okay
let's call Dax and tell him how things
went down eating Bubba nauseous hey
mister Dex get us that table at the
afterlife just my gut no you know well
you were right too
[Music]
[__] I can't believe it I know major
leagues
we're in means pride the door open but
the only thing I want to pry open right
now is a bottle of scotch oh no not
another three nighter what Bob would
need to get to know this city jack
not just gun in hand I'm gonna birthday
amen I now we finished the job but our
story is just beginning
[Music]
this concludes our gameplay demo 1
thanks for
[Music]
can
you
hi we're back
hey everyone sorry my producer just
started the video before I was even set
but we just watched the cyberpunk 2077
demo if you have been keeping up with
our stuff since e3 that was the first
time we saw it
behind closed doors for some anyone saw
it really yes I assume oh yeah thanks
Jenna Luke um so I don't know what's the
first thing that came to like what's the
what's the most know something like I
know people I wouldn't jump in like the
first person perspective because that
was like a lot of people who might be
like Witcher 3 purists or CD Projekt RED
purist we're a little bit worried to put
make it an understatement that there was
the first person but I think demo shows
that it clearly works they know what
they're doing it might be an obvious
thing but it's about immersion right
it's about feeling like you're really
embedded in that world and you're having
the experience of the character you've
created I think that's a you know that
goes hand in hand with first-person so I
think it totally works I'm really with
it the open-world itself seems built to
really just keep you in raptured and
what's happening so yeah no problems for
me Robbie you also saw it at e3 I think
we sought it a Gamescom as well a few
people behind closed doors thing to end
it a few minutes to it there were some
changes from the demo we saw me and you
were noticing like some scenes played
out at nighttime the last one manly yeah
when you kind of meet back up with the I
don't know if of corporation the one who
hacked into your mind is back whoever
that character was she meet up with her
in the end that was Nate a nighttime
Vista it was not for us I know Lucy saw
it at Gamescom who had seen at e3 and
she had like a different I want to say
an outcome out of like you know a
butterfly a butterfly effect branch but
like there were minor things yeah that
seems a little different another one
that I have noticed and then I don't
know I'm like second-guessing it but um
that really also kind of I want to say
sequence but it's all one sequence
really right when you leave your
apartment and you go downstairs and and
the narrator's saying that there are all
these ads around the world you can
interact with them and if you do you can
have your HUD pinpoint where said and
item is and in this case it was like a
vending machine for us I want to say
that it was like a like a peril clothing
store or something like that but
I want to say the narrator was like oh
we're not gonna go there but you can see
your HUD lineup um and it's just close
by is the store yeah like the arm Smith
there's a character there they hand it
out like the thing that like gets me
riled up among many things is this oh
this open-world hub of just outside your
apartment right like it just feels like
such a great area to like prep and like
get your day going or get your you know
just your pre check for a mission it's
just so lively and so dense
yeah we're just saying forget about your
mission boxing here looks like they've
mentioned a few times if there's no or I
mean they show during the demo as well
when you're coming down that elevator
it's not like it's a sky is loading
screen it looks like what was already
like loaded they I think they've been
making a big deal about the fact that
there are no at least in the demo there
are no loading screens I don't know if
they could do that throughout the whole
game they potentially could I mean so
the the one scene where your characters
in the car driving with was his name Dex
oh yeah yeah like yeah I'm pretty sure
there's like you know there's loading
stuff happening right but just the idea
of a loading screen mm-hmm I know you've
said that the elevator is not even
masking loading but let's be honest this
thing is constantly streaming data sure
they can do it yeah and do it things
have done it Rob you did mention as far
as like busi seeing something else in
the butterfly effect this is still
obviously it's CG paretic red is very
much an RPG and we saw that throughout
this demo the quests you get from what
was it was named acts you say yes yes
okay so the quest you get from the quest
giver from then on or even before like
obviously you know you go to the Ripper
talk and that's kind of how you that's
part of the upgrades at this game there
you did see some like shop heads-up
displays with weapons and stuff
obviously there's probably gonna be like
some sort of market places uh much like
I don't know they're about blacksmiths
in Witcher 3 but you get to kind of
choose how you approach this quest
there's one point toward the end where
you hack into someone in the building
that gives you a map of the rest of the
layout of the building which then allows
you to turn the power off while you're
fighting the boss this is very much a
it's supposed to be a choice driven RPG
despite the fact that there are first
person shooting elements
I don't know did we see I'm trying to
think of anything else changed from the
e3 demo and I think they made the same
choices like I was
very much the same down on everything
but it kind of reminds me of like a much
faster pace Deus Ex or at least the more
recently yeah I don't know if it's like
you know like what they were aiming for
obviously that was a more slow-paced
kind of immersive sim but it looks like
you know like CD projects like world
building acumen is carrying over here to
say the least but I do as far as the
combat goes talk about that because
there was we saw a firefight at the
beginning with Jackie your partner and
you kind of flanking a few these people
when you're investigating that crime
scene and then taking that the synth
woman out while the medics came to
figure out which that part alone was
awesome wasn't there like wall
destruction and stuff from people yeah I
read through walls he would yeah there's
bullet penetration as far as uh
beforehand I like this you kind of like
the silences over the water yeah there's
some basic slow-mo I want to say
mechanics involved here and then
throughout right like the kind of like
the knee sliding I want to say that's
that's kind of like yeah like a like an
in group like I'm like a UH how would
you say like like a core mechanic of
this game like the one wasn't there like
slow most type stuff where she's like
sliding well they definitely showed a
bunch of sort of advanced combat stuff
later on with weapons that hooks in
there yeah yeah that's like that seems
like a fundamental like ability to have
with the combat I guess is what I'm
trying to say and then later on it's
those weapons and other augmentations
right that come into play there's that
there's a fight later on where you have
a shotgun and you see the Ricochet
ability I think it's specific to that
weapon but you could see I love how the
heads-up display shows it like the the
arrows coming off the wall are blue if
you're aiming at somebody and then you
see as soon as they killed a person they
become red and like they're not eating
anybody so I you know like you also see
the augmentations earlier that like you
know like connect you to your weapon
here's a bullet penetration later on the
boss fight make like really showcases
the mobility which for an RPG seems so
like not over-the-top in a bad way but
it's just for an RPG so unconventional
yeah like they've done a great job
marrying third I was gonna say
third-person passion but it's not even
but like third-person like action in a
first-person perspective yeah
in an RPG like that's I think people are
maybe a little bit surprised at how
unconventional this game is going to be
but that's one of the reasons to be
excited for it I think yeah I wouldn't
say it's like titanfall two levels of
mobility but it definitely takes cues
from it sure and then I do want to talk
about the script and the writing we were
just talking about this before we went
live to me it always felt since I saw it
a few months ago it felt like very
stereotypical cyberpunk kind of forced
grittiness me if that's the the phrase I
don't know Rob that you like what you're
seeing of a script so far I don't know I
I don't mind it as much maybe some
people do like it is like camping away
that's that's Peter I don't know I don't
know like I feel like as far as
everything that you see like if that's
the one thing that maybe is is
frustrating to some extent I'm so ready
to pass it off like yeah yeah but but I
will say that yeah like the things that
kind of roll make me realize is what is
when you're so force-feeding like or
forcing into swearing in general that's
my problem
yeah the swearing in general where it's
like not natural like I feel like even
in real life you can pick that up on
people or it's like you just threw in
the effort for no reason but trying to
like you know raise the energy level or
whatever grab the swearing is a part of
speech it's fine but yeah definitely
Jackie's character seems to just have
been like pumped up with curse words for
added color and I don't think this game
needs that I feel like he had a really
rough time in grade school and it's like
taking it out now later in life everyone
else just gonna cruise he was a co-lead
in like high school I want to give CD
Projekt the benefit of doubt obviously
they they have shown that they can write
very good games The Witcher 3 but part
of the fun of seeing that wasn't really
necessarily coming across your own
immersion stuff that was just seeing how
they handled certain quest lines as they
played out and then come back later the
game again I would agree that this demo
isn't super promising in that regard but
based on their past portfolio I'm sure
I'm not too worried this scene was very
I like this scene too as far as I don't
know how
yeah I I really like I don't know
there's the tension that's involved but
also I wonder how much of this would be
scripted if you were playing or how many
different Brad branches you could take
if you were to choose a different
dialogue option yeah it is really neat
with the dialogue options because there
are a couple of omens I think just
coming up when you pull your guns out
that are stripped look just like what's
goal is fun like let's shoot this guy I
feel like you're seeing a lot of those
branches and it's it's interesting it's
just a very cool way of letting you know
like reminding you that you have that
ability to just like go in like in any
direction I don't know I just feel like
with so many like dialogue options and
games like it's you can still fall back
into a linear like planned out how come
but here it's like right here draw
weapons hey you know it's like hey but
you just just just did like rile him up
or straight up just like forget
everything and just go into a fun gun
fight I don't know it's just that's
really mean you wouldn't go to gun fight
from drawing your weapon who knows yeah
you don't know it's tempting right I
also really like earlier we talked about
dialogue options and whatnot and we're
time I was talking about hacking how you
can hack into someone they also do the
same to you when you have the gun to
your head when you first meet that quest
NPC and she says are you alone and you
lie and they know you're lying because
they're hacked into you and then she's
like someone else is here with him and
then that she sends the drone off to
look for him again it's probably
scripted for the purpose of the demo but
the drone comes back at the very end of
the demo like I wonder how many
different ways that could play out based
on what we've seen with CD Projekt stuff
and how much they're saying it's an RPG
here you see the beginning when you
first meet her and so if you didn't
watch this whole thing your partner
Jackie it's like up on a bridge above
you kind of sort of older seeing things
ish and then they're asking you and
they're all they hack into you to give
you a kind of cyberpunk defibrillator
not defibrillator what's a lie detector
why detector test remember the
scientific name after the stream ends
I'm sure yeah I'm drawing a blank as
well yeah but in all all in all I this
makes me excited I mean this is the
first time I've watched it all the way
through since around III and I'm sure
people
we'll be combing through it yeah this
isn't our first reaction I'm curious
hella who haven't seen this before
reacting but it is an awesome reminder
that I am still very excited for this
game and yeah if you're if you're kind
of coming late to the party CD Projekt
since like 1:00 a.m. Pacific this
morning was teasing out mysterious code
on their twitch channel now the gameplay
video is live we have all seen it now
and if you want to go catch it up with
it we have breakouts and stuff on
GameSpot and YouTube whether you want to
look at the combat the modding upgrades
etc and if you want to watch the whole
thing we also have that and hopefully
everybody got the chance to watch it but
again you can go catch up if not is
there anything else I missed that you
guys want to talk about the demo mmm
the driving was kind of cool right yeah
I know the first person or throw that's
you can go third person with driving
when we've mentioned that before but
just good yeah well and they mentioned
cars motorcycles and other vehicles so
that fouls back because for a while
people were thinking that they were
gonna be flying vehicles right because
I'm like one of the trailers or not the
first trailer there's a flying like a
police car well there's one in this the
medics come right to my right and they
hold you a gun please steal it
so they stated that you cannot you do
not have the freedom to use any flying
vehicles only in select missions is what
I think maybe that line is referring to
but who knows maybe there's like hover
bikes or hover cars not necessarily that
are a lot you know flying cars but maybe
you're you know permitted only to like
hover just above the ground motorcycles
yeah rollerblades that be free but what
other are in Mars or via or motorcycles
could there be a subway system yeah
public transportation that you can ride
man it was so cool when like this ends
here they pull off and they it just
feels like you know like the boonies
right outside of the city I mean and yes
so dense otherwise it's that's exactly
right it's still so dense you see like
you know host people walk around
homeless guy over there oh it says
homeless man so neat just to to think of
this whole city like I don't know it's
insane it's you got some basil the
little labels coming off a go above
people yeah that's always nice
yeah all and all still very promising
and here
yes I hope that this you know I don't
know how many people were actually that
worried that they were going first
person but I hope this shows how
integral it is to what they're going for
again I think CD Projekt has proven that
they know what they're doing but and
there's and they're not above criticism
but I I do
I think it's I'm very excited for how
they're using that first person like
pizza for that immersion but um yeah
anyway that was the CD Projekt RED
second phone twenty seventy seven forty
five fifty minute gameplay demo that we
originally saw during e3 Gamescom now
the whole public can see it which is
awesome if we miss anything please let
us know I'm sure we missed a ton even
though we've seen it like what three
times now there's a lot of time so much
in there yeah and then we'll have other
breakout videos going up on YouTube
GameSpot and also we'll just have like
stuff going up throughout the day
throughout the week
beep Rob thanks for joining me thank you
thank you and thank you everybody for
joining us here on GameSpot we will see
you around
you